et on va plus loin avec l'historien
françois durpaire bonjour françois
rauger raphaël cannes est avec nous
depuis washington le correspondant de
france 24 aux états unis matthieu mabin
bonjour mathieu
mais vous voyez un gros décalage avec
washington c'était donc hier le point
final de six semaines de débats qui ont
tenu en haleine l'amérique et une partie
du monde via internet et les réseaux
sociaux la retransmission en direct des
audiences au procès hurd versus depp
marque un tournant dans l'actualité aux
états unis et peut être aussi dans la
perception du mouvement mis tous au
coeur des débats l'actrice amber heard
reconnu coupable de diffamation et
condamné à verser 10 millions de dollars
de dommages et intérêts à son ex époux
mondialement connu lui aussi johnny depp
il avait porté plainte après la
publication d'une tribune le washington
post voilà quatre ans dans laquelle la
comédienne se disait victime de
violences conjugales
chacun avait reconnu johnny depp comme
l'auteur de ces violences condamnation
dans les deux sens saint françois
durpaire puisque johnny depp doit lui
aussi des dommages et intérêts à m
bergues pour des propos tenus par son
avocat mais d'un montant moindre à on
parle de 2 millions le jury a choisi son
camp dans la guerre que se livrent les
deux ex époux oui très clairement les
deux millions de ces voix là c'est pour
dire on met pas tous nos oeufs du même
côté mais oui le jury a choisi son camp
d'autant plus que c'est une surprise
parce que johnny depp il avait été
débouté en grande bretagne or pour la
diffamation que généralement les
américains ils vont du côté de la grande
bretagne parce qu'ils savent que c'est
plus facile alors là qu'est ce qui s'est
passé aux états unis il ya trois choses
la première c'est que c'est des jurés
est pas un juge la deuxième chose c'est
le talent des avocats de deux des têtes
qui ont utilisé une méthode qui
s'appelle la méthode darveau qui en
particulier consiste a dit nyan y est
attaquée attaque et rivers a renversé la
victime qui devient le coupable est le
coupable qui devient la victime l'a de
victimes c'est devenu et c'est devenu
cet acteur que beaucoup beaucoup
d'américains aime johnny depp et donc il
ya aussi le fait que c'était transparent
les débats étaient transparents et donc
c'est une surprise par qu'il suffisait
de pas grand chose pas pour prouver
juste qui avait pas diffamation s'il ya
que même si elle l avait peut-être donné
des coups l'a reconnu s'il y avait même
un climat extrêmement toxique bah si lui
a donné des coups c'était pas une
diffamation donc c'est vraiment un film
gasco de son camp d'ailleurs a fait
appel alors on le sait on le sait
aujourd'hui alors on va y revenir sans
doute est ce que c'est effectivement des
conséquences pour le mouvement mitu il
ya une autre nouvelle aujourd'hui à
raphaël on a appris que en appel harvey
waste in a perdu ça c'est important ça
veut dire que tout ne va pas dans le
même sens aux états unis qui a pas
forcément un reflux du mouvement mitu je
rappelle qu'au moment où la sphère
westin et éclate il ya une hausse dans
31 pays du monde + 10 % des plaintes en
matière sexuelle donc c'est ce mouvement
là donc la parole qui s'est libérée demi
tout mais là attention il n'est pas
d'ailleurs dans un quelque chose qui
était sexuelle origines c'est des coups
c'est de la violence conjugale à
l'origine ce n'était pas quelque chose
de btu mais c'est vrai qu'on parle de
plus en plus par exemple du mouvement
hashtag même tout qui vient d'inde qui
vient de karen oberoi vous savez cet
acteur qui a été accusé à tort en 2019
et ce mouvement hashtag mène tout il
arrive aujourd'hui aux états unis en
tout cas amber heard et johnny depp ne
s'y sont pas trompés c'est bien un
jugement un verdict à charge contre
l'actrice est au bénéfice de l'acteur en
juger en tout cas par leur réaction à
l'énoncé du verdict pour un besançon
dans son tweet a publié juste après
voilà ce qu'elle écrit la déception que
je ressens aujourd'hui et au delà des
mots j'ai le coeur brisé que la montagne
de preuves n'étaient pas suffisantes
pour résister au pouvoir à l'influencé à
l'emprise disproportionné de mon ex mari
évidemment elle désigne par la johnny
depp et puis pour johnny je vous propose
d'écouter justement ce qu'il a à ce
qu'il a écrit lui dans son tweet le jury
me ramène à la vie j'ai toujours appris
à mes enfants à dire la vérité je me
sens en paix désormais
matthieu mabin angie gens de la sorte à
le jury s'est prononcé sur les faits
eux-mêmes ils disent que johnny depp de
violences conjugales à l'encontre des
arabes
alors c'est justement une excellente
question puisque concrètement le
tribunal n'a pas directement statuer sur
une plainte pour violences conjugales
justement déposé par an lorsque on le
sait à l'encontre de johnny depp mais on
l'a compris la question qui a été posée
aux jurés répondait à une plainte de
johnny depp qui poursuivait son ex femme
en diffamation d encre et donc on l'a vu
à la question amber heard s'est elle
rendue coupable de propos diffamatoires
à l'encontre de johnny depp les jurés
ont répondu par l'affirmative on l'a
évoqué également quelques formules
maladroites prononcé par l'avocat de
johnny depp ont également été retenu
cette fois contre le plaignant
puisqu'elle aussi ont été jugés
diffamatoires rappelons qu'à l'origine
les propos de ben bernanke ont été
relayées après une interview dans la
presse américaine qu'elle interviewe
remonte à des années et donc pour
répondre directement à votre question
oui il a été question à multiples
reprises durant le procès de démontrer
les violences conjugales d'où un débat
pour lequel s'est passionné l'amérique
et qui a reposé sur des témoignages des
photos des photos d'ecchymoses des
vidéos volées mais au bout du compte l
intime conviction des jurés et c'est
tout ce qui compte est que s'il y avait
eu violence conjugale elle était
réciproque d'une part et dans des
proportions équivalentes mais que
surtout signé ni d'un côté ni de l'autre
suffisamment de preuves n'ont été
apportées mais il faut rappeler que la
justice américaine la justice européenne
s'exprime très différemment les jurés
ont bien répondu à la question johnny
depp at il été diffamé par l'affirmative
mais il existe une loi fédérale aux
états unis qui dit qu'un homme ne peut
pas être jugé fois pour la même affaire
en clair les deux parties ont utilisé
tous les éléments de preuve en leur
possession pour se décrédibiliser mario
tu sais ce qu'on a vu c'est le spectacle
qui a été livré à la nuit reliques et il
faudrait les éléments lourds et surtout
nouveau pour qu'il y ait un nouveau
procès je ne parle pas de la peine en
clair il faudra une nouvelle affaire
pour que johnny depp ou son ex femme
soit finalement jugé pour violences
conjugales n'y at il pas tout de même un
problème françois durpaire à ce que les
réseaux sociaux est pris à ce point fait
et cause pour johnny depp est ce que ça
pu influencer les jurés comme le
contexte des émeutes on s'en souvient
los angeles lors du procès au jay
simpson dans la mesure où c'est un
procès qui était un cirque médiatique
tik tok twitch un peu l'équivalent doji
simpson à la télévision là on l'a eue
sur les réseaux sociaux à la différence
que j simpson on regarde passivement
devant son écran les réseaux sociaux on
interagit et on al'impression tous
d'être juré est de pouvoir dire alors
c'est quoi un c il ya un split d'à côté
on a le visage de l'un le visage de
l'autre et on se dit bâle un à l'air
plus honnête que l'autre ou l'un fait la
comédie l'une fait la comédie l'autre
est un bon acteur low travers honnête
c'est pas ça la justice et le problème
c'est que ça rentre en collusion avec le
fait que les jurés n'étaient pas
séquestrés donc ils ont pu entendre le
bruit du procès médiatique qui
évidemment a pesé sur les épaules de
amber heard et pas du tout de johnny
depp qui a été est largement soutenue ça
aussi c'est un signe des temps il a été
soutenu par des hommes et des femmes par
ses fans pas seulement prenons l'exemple
de dior il ya quelques temps dans un
contexte hashtag mythe ou une célébrité
n'ont pas condamné mais accusaient même
sur un fondement de rumeurs aucune
marque ne voulait travailler et il y
avait une mesure conservatoire dior non
seulement conserve son égérie lemay
égérie d'un parfum qui s'appelle sauvage
vous avez sans doute vu l'image
évidemment qui évoque évocatoire avec ce
qu'on entende violence etc
il n'y a pas eu de boycott du parfum il
n'y a pas eu de pétitions tiens je
pourrais org personne n'a été amenés à
boycotter dior qui vend des vêtements
pour les femmes qui se dit féministe et
là évidemment on est sur quelque chose
de postes mis tout même si le mouvement
me to continue à vivre lui johnny depp
dit tout de même que sa carrière
cinématographique a subi un coup d'arrêt
c'est un c'est une réalité et on a
beaucoup parlé de l'émotionnel de amber
heard parlons aussi de l'émotionnel de
johnny depp parce que il a tout perdu
effectivement sur le plan professionnel
et c'était dur à évaluer 15 millions
revisité à 350 milles vous le savez en
dommages et intérêts punitifs
pourquoi parce que c'est difficile de
deviner les rôles qu'il n'a pas eu le
manque à gagner il y à des dommages
émotionnel il parle beaucoup de ces
enfants on se rappelle d'une célèbre
actrice vanessa paradis pour qui
peut-être il a quitté il a peut-être ça
en tête aussi que sa vie est d'avant
était une vie où tout lui souriait
disney
d'aider des films vus dans le monde
entier à la fois du cinéma d'auteur du
cinéma à grand public et là tout est
tombé par terre c'est fini pour lui même
même au contenu du verdict est en ce
sens un avenir cinématographique sa
carrière et tout les reste hypothéqué
par entacher tout de même par le soupçon
violence non parce que les trois
premiers jours ont pesé dans la balance
il a un peu fait non pas son mea culpa
sur les coûts il et ils dénient cela met
sur sa personnalité son enfance casser
tout ça il l'a dit il l'a dit à
l'amérique et il a voulu la transparence
des débats et vous savez les histoires
de come back aux états unis les
américains aiment cela et on dit souvent
aux états unis la notoriété négatif
c'est de la notoriété quand même et peut
se transformer en notoriété positive il
a sans doute un avenir attention parce
que ça c'était du civil tout à fait
d'accord avec ce que dit mathieu sauf
qu'il pourrait y avoir une attaque au
pénal de la part de amber heard savoir
si elle a les moyens vous savez c'est
une histoire de gros sous ou aux états
unis faut payer les avocats et et enfin
il va falloir qu'elle paye environ 9000
$ millions par dans de dollars pour
pouvoir continuer en appel n'est pas
suspensif
aura-t-elle les moyens d'attaquer au
pénal a quand même parler de quelque
chose qui était relatif à un viol
pendant cette histoire et là on était je
vous rappelle aux civils ni l'un ni
l'autre ne risquer la prison oui ça
pourrait effectivement changé merci
beaucoup françois durpaire et nous vous
saluons parce que vous vous devez partir
mais on va continuer à en parler avec
vous mathieu parce que ce procès bien
sûr il intervient dans une américain qui
ces dernières années a été effectivement
l'objet de ce qu'on appelle la vague
mitu qui s'est répandu d'ailleurs un peu
partout dans le monde ce jugement d'hier
et ce qu'ils portent un coup d'arrêt
justement à ceux à cette vague mytho
je voudrais ce que disait françois
durpaire en tout début d'émission qui a
déjà effleuré le sujet c'est mais c'est
encore difficile à dire en réalité ici
aux etats unis des associations qui
militent soit pour l'égalité hommes
femmes soit pour la dénonciation des
crimes sexistes et sexuelles considère
que me to a globalement rempli son rôle
et qu'il y a désormais un avant et un
après l'amérique passait déjà pour l'un
des pays qui codifie le plus la relation
homme-femme dans le travail en tout cas
et ce même si hollywood avait on le sait
un peu échappé à ses règles et donc même
si effectivement ce process est commuée
en une bataille pour la défense du droit
des femmes la libération de la parole la
défaite d'anders earth n'annonce pas
plus de répercussions que cela d'abord
parce que c'est d'abord sa défaite et
non pas celle du mouvement mis tout ça
c'est clair ce qui serait un comble et
ensuite parce que les affaires qui ont
été révélés dans le sillage de mitu on
pense à l'affairé flynn évidemment
largement suffi à des crédits à
crédibiliser une mouvement il ya
cependant une nuance qui pourraient être
apportées par ce verdict l'idée que la
parole des hommes incriminés n'est
clairement pas effacée par la libération
de la parole des femmes ce qui est un
débat et si aux états unis pour preuve
un jury populaire américain peu en son
âme et conscience donné raison à un
homme sur la base d'éléments probants
c'est ce à quoi on vient d'assister
états unis toujours matière à l'un lors
même que certains des enfants tués lors
de la fusillade ou velde et au texas
n'ont pas encore été enterré une
nouvelle tuerie par arme à feu a
endeuillé cette fois l'état voisin de
l'oklahoma c'était hier dans un hôpital
de tel saint un patient mécontent a tué
quatre personnes dont deux médecins
c'est dans ce contexte qu'un groupe de
sénateurs à 4 républicains cinq
démocrates disent que des moyens de
cadres et l'accès aux armes à feu joe
biden doit s'exprimer à nouveau dans les
prochaines heures que va dire mathieu le
président américain
alors d'abord il ya un point important
c'est que toutes les victimes nous
valent d n'ont pas été enterrés 21
enterrement qui vont s'échelonner
jusqu'au 15 juin donc encore pour deux
bonnes semaines et donc conformément à
ses habitudes joe biden ne va pas tout
de suite quitté le registre
compassionnel c'est ça que ça veut dire
y est il est on le sait le président
américain le mieux à même de comprendre
le désastre qui a frappé les 21 une
famille américaine ce jour-là
vingt-et-une familles américaines et par
extension le texas tout entier et le
pays il on le met évidemment devant le
congrès ce parterre de sénateurs devant
lequel le président va s'exprimer
effectivement il ne pourra pas être
question que de condoléances ou
l'imaginé bien le président américain
est désormais attendu sur des mots sur
concrètes il va donc se faire le
porte-voix de ces familles de victimes
qui l'ont interpellé lorsqu'il s'est
rendu avec la première dame à un bal des
sept derniers jours en clair le
président va s'adresser au congrès des
états unis et particulièrement aux
sénateurs on l'a compris et
particulièrement parmi ces sénateurs
auraient public quelques objectifs sont
atteignables pour lui comme le fait de
remonter l'âge légal pour acquérir une
arme à 21 ans et non plus à 18 ans ce
serait un premier pas en tout cas ce
serait considéré comme tel ensuite vous
le savez il y a également un débat pour
savoir comment durcir les règles du bac
brun tchèque cette procédure qui impose
un examen médical et psychiatrique et
une vérification des antécédents
judiciaires mais à cela les partisans de
l'interdiction diront que ça ne suffit
pas joe biden est déjà à l'origine d'une
loi qui était parvenue à interdire
certaines catégories d'armes mais là
encore le droit américain n'a pas su
sanctuary zay cette loi qui est devenu
obsolète et qui a disparu et entre temps
la lra on présente plus a su consolider
son argumentaire et n'hésitent pas
désormais à défier la maison blanche ni
plus ni moins par des slogans du type
vous voulez mon fusil venait le chercher
des slogans que l'on entend jusque dans
les clips de campagne des candidats au
congrès leon hill se dit un que des
républicains pourrait néanmoins voter
ces mesures alors il faudrait il en
faudra au moins 10 1 pour parvenir
vraiment un changement notable de la de
la législation quels arguments plus
aujourd'hui la nra pour tenter de
convaincre justement d'un statu quo
après ces fusillades
alors vous avez parlé du sénateur
démocrate chris murphy j'ouvrirai juste
une parenthèse sur lui et le sénateur du
connecticut du connecticut où résonnent
encore la furie de sandy hook en 2012
vous avez le sénateur chris murphy c'est
cet homme qui a pris la parole dans les
minutes qui ont suivi l'annoncé de la
tuerie dauwalder il est donc
particulièrement bien placé pour
s'exprimer la tuerie de sandy hook un
carnage encore plus atroce que celui de
nouvelles d eux mais effectivement il a
face à lui des élus comme la sénatrice
susan collins républicaine qui elle
tranche avec les propos de la nra vous
connaissez l'argumentaire de la lra 7 ce
puissant lobby des armes américain qui
considère que la faute ne peut pas
incomber aux armées elles-mêmes mais bel
et bien aux porteurs des armes et qu'il
n'est donc pas question modifier la
législation
cette sénatrice susan collins
républicaine donc qui effectivement
confirme que quelques mesures pourraient
être débattues sereinement entre
sénateurs jusqu'à hypothétiquement voir
le jour la question des chargeurs à
grande capacité notamment fait partie
des sujets qui seront débattus mais si
vous me permettez d'ouvrir une
parenthèse à chaque tuerie et elles ont
été nombreuses depuis août depuis de
puits ou valve des pardons et donc elles
ne sont pas dissuasives à chaque tuerie
la question de la législation revient
sur le terrain et devant les chiffres
absolument astronomique des morts par
balles aux états unis chaque année cette
question d'un législation au culte de
grandes réalités une écrasante majorité
des morts par balles sont tués par des
armes illégales ce qui vient contredire
la stratégie des démocrates
d'aujourd'hui voire par des armes
fantôme vous savez ces armes fabriquées
à la maison par des imprimantes 3d la
législation ne résoudront pas le
problème et ensuite j'en terminerai par
là comment ne pas parler de l'utopie
d'exercer un contrôle total sur les
armes si ce contrôle s'opposent et c'est
le cas à la culture américaine et allant
de l'identité même de l'amérique c'est
l'une des grandes différences qui oppose
l'europe et des états unis mary giner
américain ce pays est née en même temps
que le code est selon l'adage de
l'inventeur du ray vers le col a rendu
les hommes égaux merci matthieu mabin
c'est terminé pour on va plus loin merci
d'avoir été avec nous depuis washington
avec donc on l'a vu un françois durpaire
dans le début de cette émission rester
avec nous on se retrouve dans deux
minutes pour un nouveau journal
[Musique]